what the crown has always done so
cleverly I think is not tried to imitate
the characters but to sort of evoke them
the crown season five is here and just
like you expected this season is full of
attention to detail and underlying
themes so stick around for all of the
details that went into creating the
crown season five number one the slowest
makeover Ever that's one way you might
describe what Diana went through in
season 5 of the crown to help Mark the
emotional journey of Diana's character
costume designers came up with some
rules for how to dress her in the first
few episodes she wears long skirts and
baggy sweaters softer shapes that
suggest a formlessness or a sense of
hiding from the world in later episodes
her skirts get shorter and her
silhouette becomes simpler and more
defined to show a stripped back Diana
regaining control of her life it's kind
of an evolution story in the sense of
watching somebody sort of find their
Center again Elizabeth Debicki wasn't
the only one undergoing unusual
makeovers this season Johnny Lee Miller
had more than a few special makeup
treatments thanks to some frequent black
eyes and bruising but more on that later
number two turn the music up Johnny Lee
Miller played John Major but he also
played the Royal DJ on set for season
five of the crown Johnny would help pass
the time during things like lengthy wig
fitting sessions by DJing for the crew
he also kept the makeup artists busy as
an avid martial artist Johnny would
often come to set with a black eye he
once even had his finger tattooed
between shooting days isn't there a rule
about that somewhere I'm quite relaxed
but yeah it's just bizarre Johnny seems
to be a far cry from the quiet and
gentle stealiness of John Major number
three hold your horses or let them ride
the crown season 5 actor Jonathan price
was taught to handle horses by some of
Prince Philip's real life racing friends
for the carriage racing scenes in this
season although Jonathan learned to
handle reigns with real horses in the
scene from the show The Carriage is
actually pulled by a cam camera truck
better safe than sorry number four
things got a little too real this season
the crown has made use of an elaborate
collection of props and set pieces some
were created for the show and some were
actually antiques production for the
crown had a major setback when 150
000 pounds worth of props were stolen
from production trucks set decorator
Allison Harvey recalled one of the worst
things that happened this season was
three of the prop trucks with our
antiques got broken into overnight all
the Antiques were stolen Harvey
explained it was obviously a nightmare
because we had to try to replace them
quickly when the crime was reported the
police said they didn't have time to
investigate the theft because they had
found a body in the river nearby the
body turned out to be a prosthetic
belonging to the production team of the
crown and was one of the items stolen
from the back of the trucks we'll try to
get it back actually really the police
still got it number five is that a smirk
or a quirk all of the actors on season 5
had to undergo some fairly intense
transfer formations to play these iconic
characters convincingly and while
sometimes these Transformations can be
complicated other times there are simple
short tricks I suppose it starts with a
jaw and it's so sort of because the
jaw's so tight Dominic West says that
one of the secrets to speaking like
Charles was to talk slightly from the
side of his mouth Dominic describes the
motion as a man stopping words from
slipping out out of fear for saying the
wrong thing keeping it simple number six
you thought you spotted a few Grays
didn't you to help Mark the passage of
time over the years that the crown
covers the hair and makeup Department
would do things like use half a dozen
wigs on a single actor Imelda Staunton
wears six different wigs throughout the
series she starts with the same wig for
the six episodes gains a few white
pieces for the next three episodes and
has a wider lighter wig for episode 10
showing the passing of five years and
the toll that time has taken on the
queen number seven another season
another decade as the show moves into
the 90s the direct actors tried to mimic
the bright and colorful trends of the
era camera movements are more free and
the color palette in the opening
episodes is much lighter than previous
Seasons if you watch or re-watch
carefully you'll notice that this
colorful palette does fade over the
season to match the darker tone of the
drama number eight everything the light
touches and some of those things in the
dark too set decorator Alison Harvey was
in charge of creating a believable world
for the crown actors to live in and that
proved to be a challenge all of its own
hopefully by the end of it it looks
like someone lives there Allison
describes the approach to creating a
world that is both believable for the
viewers and inhabitable for the actors
we start with the flooring the lighting
the big lumps of furniture ultimately
you end up with a paper knife it's like
moving house every day Allison's
expertise was used not only to create a
believable world for viewers like you to
enjoy but for the actors to believe they
were really a part of it we can only
imagine the secrets buried in each set
and prop piece and we can probably all
agree with Dominic West when he says so
much goes unseen and unthanked number
nine have you got those Royal moves you
might say the cast of season five
certainly do thanks to their Royal
choreographer the cast worked with
movement coach Paulie Bennett to better
capture the performance of their
characters with body language Paulie
explains things like how Diana greets a
crowd from the back to the front
sometimes crouching to greet kids up
close for Elizabeth whenever she had to
do those big crowd scenes it wasn't an
overwhelming
experience Paulie also suggested to
Imelda Stanton that she should think of
pressing her big toes into the floor and
square off her hips in her stance in
order to portray the Queen's quiet
confidence in entering a room so just
those little things are sort of helpful
few for an actor on a film set number
10. Britannia rule the waves if you
watch carefully you might notice that
season 5 uses the Royal yacht called the
Britannia as a metaphor for the royal
family in the early 90s in the earlier
Seasons the Britannia was the Queen's
first home a place she had total control
over when she first sat upon the throne
in the later Seasons the yacht is in
disrepair just as the Royal Family's own
standing becomes tarnished in the show
just as people question the need for the
yacht the show depicts TV shows of the
time questioning the role of the royal
family number 11. the Apple doesn't fall
far from the tree in season 5 Prince
William is played by San and West who is
Dominic West's real-life son they said
we can't find a blue-eyed blonde boy 13
who's starting boarding school I said I
think I've got just the guy you might
say the two didn't have to do much
acting for their relationship as father
and son what's even cooler is that
playing Prince William on the crown is
sennon's first acting role proud father
Dominic said it was amazing suddenly
seeing his son on camera number 12.
James is that you you might have thought
there was something about Mr Townsend in
season five that's because former 007
Timothy Dalton joined the cast as Peter
Townsend to tell the story of his
reunion with Margaret after years apart
Timothy was suggested to the casting
team by Leslie Manville who plays
Margaret Leslie enjoyed the bond
connection saying it's very Margaret
isn't it to be dancing with James Bond
she'd have loved it number 13 wait for
real Dominic West had a secret advantage
while learning to play Charles he has
actually met the real-life counterpart
of his character several times West said
I've been in line to shake his hand a
few times and it's fascinating it's very
useful to meet the character you're
playing obviously another season of the
crown and yet another compelling
depiction of these historic characters
and with that another set of curious
stories around how the details of season
five were brought to life this is only a
short list of the tales from behind the
scenes so what did we miss what do you
think let us know in the comments below
[Music]